ich rege mich derzeit über auf ich rege
mich über diesen ganzen wahnsinn vielen
deutschland stattfindet auf wir leben in
einer demokratie und trotzdem glauben
kleine gruppen von meinungsdiktatur der
mehrheitsgesellschaft ihre gefüllten
wahrheiten aufzwingen zu können und so
wird unsere gesellschaft nur noch mehr
gespalten
wir haben durch diese minderheiten
minderbemittelten und selbst mit leider
frau allem so viele und so große
probleme die wirklich zu einer gefahr
werden können und vor allem zu einer
gefahr werden können für die frauensache
vergleich dar um gleichberechtigung ich
habe drei themen die hauptsächlich damit
zu tun haben sexismus rassismus sexismus
will ich gar nicht groß sagen das hat
mir den letzten tagen häufig zu
rassismus kann ich nur ein zwei sätze zu
sagen und zwar
glaubt die welt wirklich nicht die welt
oder in deutschland wirklich migranten
oder farbige menschen können keine
rassisten sein ich bin eine frau mit 100
prozent migrationshintergrund und ich
kann sagen
menschen mit migrationshintergrund
können sehr große und starke rassisten
sein ich weiß ganz genau wie in der
community über deutsche bio deutsche und
vor allem auch über bio deutsche frauen
gesprochen wird das war dazu uns mit dem
gender waren über sprache will ich gar
nicht sprechen darüber diskutieren wir
tagtäglich was nicht gesehen wird ist
dieses ganze trans thema wir werden drei
bis vier trans frauen im bundestag
wahrscheinlich haben die durch frauen
die durch die frauenliste also frauen
plätzchen im bundestag beratene gekommen
sind oder kommen werden und zwar das
sind männer die auch noch
biologisch komplett man sind also nicht
operiert sind aber als mann für die aber
auch rein rechtlich noch nicht 100% man
sind das bedeutet dass die frauen plätze
die hart erkämpft wurden blockiert und
weil sie es als man nicht schaffen
trotzdem so als frau weiterkommen es ist
auch wieder ein so eine gefühlte
wahrheit wenn mir das erlauben wir haben
zum beispiel bei tessa ganz ganz nah die
ist in bayern wir den bundestag landen
dies auf listenplatz 13 die wird auf
jeden fall im bundestag sitzen ihre
agenda ist es paragrafen und unser recht
komplett zu ändern weil sie das als
demütigend empfindet
zwei wirklich zwei gutachten erstellen
zu müssen damit sie ihre rechtliche
identität ändern kann das bedeutet für
sie oder er nicht für sie ist und dann
wirklich für ihn er ist ja noch ein er
dass er sich nicht da wo ich hin muss
reingehen weil ich habe die von der
serie frau gansera die übrigens für mich
eine frau ist die habe ich erlebt in der
amerikanischen botschaft war eingeladen
für bild und da hat sie und andere haben
ihre sicht erklärt und ich fand ehrlich
gesagt dass frau gansera mein mut also
mein respekt für ihren mut gehört die
ich fand es toll wenn sie auf der bühne
saßen gesagt hat ich möchte nicht als
trans frau vorgestellt werden ich bin
eine frau und ehrlich gesagt muss ich
sagen war sie das für mich und wenn sie
die entscheidung getroffen hat es ist in
ihrem pass die ist jetzt eine frau dann
ist sie jetzt ein kuvert gar nicht ob
das land wie jan o wir müssen dann
denken wir schon mal weiter nein ist sie
nicht sie hat noch einen penis ist nicht
repariert sie ist ein mann punkt das
bedeutet wenn sie 100 prozent als frau
anerkannt wird was ist der nächste
schritt das trans also dass männer die
sich auf einmal als frau fühlen und sich
von jetzt auf gleich als frau
umschreiben lassen können also wäre
rechtliche stellung ändern können dann
straftaten begehen also vergewaltiger
und dann im frauengefängnis land nur
dort fröhlich weiter vergewaltigen
können das ist nämlich in kanada in
diesen ach so liberalen landen damit
schon öfters passiert aber ich bin ein
ganz anderer mensch wieder ganz
freiheitsliebender mensch bin deswegen
auch gegen jede quote weil ich glaube
dass die quote immer das
leistungsprinzip außer kraft setzt und
deswegen sind mir parteien auch per
sieht suspekt die mit quoten arbeiten
aber wenn eine partei das für sich
entscheidet kann sie ja machen aus
freien stücken es gibt eine quote und
wenn eine partei entscheidung ich will
eine transfer ein trans man was auch
immer auf einen frauen oder männer platz
da würde ich sagen ist das einfach dann
macht die partei dass die partei weiß
das ja auch
die fütterung also
ich brauche die reche basteln alexander
du bist gar nicht mehr am thema vorbei
vasana gerade beklagt ist doch eine
komplette
volks
gehirnwäsche die gerade stattfindet das
hat doch mit diesen speziellen fallen
die dir sagt überhaupt nichts zu tun
dass seine vorkommen zu richten zurecht
sagt wir können nicht anfangen all das
mit willkür zu bestimmen wenn ich jetzt
sage ich fühle ich identifiziere mich
als dies und das wenn wir damit anfangen
selbstverständlich respektiere ich das
aber wenn wir damit anfangen sagt ich
morgen ich identifiziere mich als pferd
und warum darüber was kann ein
miteinander ist echt nicht vergleichs
kannst du
haben ein wlan für jeden oder für die
idee für denn erst mal für je ein großer
weg das zuzulassen
also ich fühle als man als frau oder
fühle mich wie eine frau
muss das irgendwie verstecken dann muss
ich es irgendwann mal offenbaren dann
meiner umwelt also meinen eltern
geschwistern vielleicht bin ich
verheiratet meiner frau dann offenbaren
da gibt es ja auch solche beispiel und
dann diesen transformationsprozess leben
damit ich endlich so ist ja die
wahrnehmung bei mir ankommen das ist
doch schon das ist
erst dann zu unterstellen entschuldigung
das tun sie ja gerade dass hier männer
die trans bewegung nutzen um sich so
einen listenplatz auf den frauen listen
zu erschleichen das ist doch wirklich
studieren kann ich eine andere sache
wirklich hirnrissig also ihre argumente
vor ganz ganz ganz lange vorher auch in
der politik aber
ich war
aber lenkt genau das was sie jetzt
gerade sagen da bin ich wirklich der
meinung dass müssen parteien
parteimitglieder delegierte können doch
entscheiden wen sie wollen die können
von mir das auch 50 frauen er braucht
ein politikum gemacht aber es
gab doch
reichweiten schon ja
ja ich hab das ist der punkt das thema
ist ja größer und darum geht's am ende
es geht um die frage muss sich
eigentlich jedes wort mit einem mit
einer pause und einem innen beenden was
ich sage muss ich eigentlich wenn ich
schreibe den seiten anschauen also sagen
das ist glaube ich ein sehr großer
aspekt das ist nämlich die frage
inwieweit reden wir haben mir sprach er
noch wie wir sie bisher hatten oder
inwieweit wird jede noch so kleine
minderheit auch in diese sprache
eingepflanzt und muss sich wiederfinden
das ist ja der punkt aber wenn jemand
privat mit gender stern sprechen und
schreiben will kann er das doch machen
der punkt ist nur es darf mir und uns
niemand aufzwingen ich glaube das ist
der punkt wir müssen uns auf eine
rechtschreibung eine offizielle und eine
offizielle sprache auch einige auf die
müssen uns verständigen aber wenn die
familie sagen zu hause keine rede
jahrhundert werden sie jetzt denken es
geht um zu gucken ob das letzte gesagt
er denke da ist frei jeder kann so mit
einigen fragen sich frauen diskriminiert
fühlen wenn man sagt pilot oder ob es
besser ist pilotin
es ist einfach die frage ob das eine
diskriminierung per se ist oder ob wir
uns öffnen müssen und sagen pilotinnen
und piloten also ganz einfach und da das
nicht von selbst kommt gibt es immer in
solchen sachen bewegungen die sowas
einfordern auch mit vehemenz und ich
will ihre kompetenz in diesem feld kann
die abqualifizieren dass man sich gar
nicht nur nur vielleicht war dieses
detail auch nicht so ganz glücklich aber
wenn sie sagen das wird uns auf
doktoriert und wir müssen uns zu
verhalten und das wollen sie nicht dann
verstehe ich das aber ich glaube es
braucht immer bei solchen änderungs
bewegungen jemand der da voran geht und
vielleicht auch hartes einfordert was
nicht gerade der dienst in eines
verstößt antworten kopf die guten
willens sind wir sind doch alle guten
willens taktvoll zu sein und
selbstverständlich möchte ich dass meine
tochter die jetzt 18 ist möchte dass die
ingenieurin werden kann und piloten
werden kann und nicht in der nähe ich
habe es genau das sieht ein bisschen
bewusstsein dafür hat aber märkte nicht
wie das ist alles was geredet als sie
schon so entsetzt reagiert dabei als ich
diesen witz gemacht haben wie eben nicht
mehr wie das alles zu spaltung willst
was 3 macht sich gesagt wenn man sich
identifizieren kann so alles was gerade
lust hat dann schaut ihr alle so
entsetzt das ist doch das zentrale ist
das zentrale wir können doch nicht
anfangen aber keine kinderarbeit zu lang
wird durchaus denken wir leiden haben
das führt doch zu der sehr gut wir haben
doch bei bild dieses format erfunden
damit wir genau das machen und
vielleicht waren unsere blicke ein
selbst sowohl ist aber nicht
unterbrochen nation steht das wäre wenn
du jetzt erst
fertig das ist von dir ein ironischer
kommentar wir beiden kennen uns gut
genug um das zu wissen ich weiß
überspitzt deswegen habe ich von anfang
gesagt wie sehr würde ich dafür schätzen
und das ist uns hier auch wichtig alle
meinungen werden gehört hier haben wir
jetzt hart debattiert aber ich will
natürlich niemand in seiner meinung
begrenzt das ist uns sehr wichtig
[Musik]